so good afternoon and thank you for
coming you know whenever I'm at a
session I always like to have the last
session of the day because I find that
the smartest best-looking most motivated
audience comes to the last session don't
you think yes so this session is about
runtime insights we're going to talk
about how to troubleshoot your
production applications and in
particular how the modern cloud is
evolving that process I'm Brad Abrams
and I'm a product manager on the cloud
platform team and I at esha moody tatran
I'm a software engineer working on the
Google cloud platform so in a recent
survey of developers we found that most
developers spend over fifty percent of
their time finding and fixing issues in
production why do we spend so much time
finding and fixing issues in production
well it's because this is a really high
stake situation when there's an issue in
production nothing else matters you have
to drop everything and work on just that
and when you're doing that it's a very
data rich environment there's lots to
look at there's logs and monitoring data
there's get dips to look at but its
information scarce it's hard to
determine what the root causes what data
you should actually be paying attention
to and if we're honest with ourselves we
have maybe an imperfect understanding of
the applications we're maintaining in
production maybe we didn't write all of
the code that's there may be somebody
else change things or may be new to the
project yet it's our job to maintain
that in production so we think in the
modern way and the modern cloud we want
to reduce this significantly we want to
take the guesswork out of production
debugging and we want to speed up that
iteration cycle the finding fix
cycle and one of the ways we're doing
that is by providing you deep system
transparency so you know what your code
is doing and you know what the system
code is doing you have a good idea of
what's going on in your application so
Google has been maintaining systems at a
high scale in production for 10-plus
years so at each as a developer at
Google you must have some really amazing
tools to use yeah we do and things are
pretty sweet here as a software engineer
at Google we get to build great products
work with awesome colleagues yeah great
food and the occasional drinks on the
beach right but even so things do go
wrong in production and when they do it
can be really hard to find out what's
going on our production deployment are
complex many people often many teams
work on one product and so when
something goes wrong one person can I
cannot understand every the intricate
details of every single every single
component in the system so fortunately
we have we have powerful internal
debugging tools that help us reason and
understand our production system and
when there's a problem we can figure out
what's going on pretty quickly and when
we started working on the Google cloud
platform we wanted to bring these
powerful tools through our users to help
them understand and debug their
production is the production system so
today we're going to talk about three
tools that will help you do just that
we're talking about cloud logs cloud
trace and cloud debugger so in order to
do that we're going to launch the emoji
translator emoji Slater it takes your
boring text and turns it into vibrant
exciting images we think this is going
to sweep the Internet after this
conference and we're going to be multi
millionaires so let's switch over to the
demo machine and take a look at what
this looks like we're going to be ready
for drinks in the city tonight right
yeah so we just enter that boring text
and we get these vibrant images we what
was the other one hat uh oh yeah your
your grandmother yeah my grandmother is
having her 84th birthday on Thursday so
happy birthday grandma that's beautiful
what was the hot dog yes Wow it it's hot
dog I don't know anyway whatever it's a
beautiful system we're already getting
over one QPS of traffic over one query
per second of traffic on this site it's
mostly simulated traffic but maybe we'll
get some hits from you but this
application has a few issues it's in
production under load but has a few
issues that we're going to walk through
the rest of this talk finding those
issues and fixing them in production on
this live site so let's switch back over
to the slides all right I will go over
the architecture of the emoji Slater the
web front end is an app running on App
Engine within the managed VMs container
when it gets a query from the user it
consults a translation service and then
looks up the image on our emoji image
store which is a layer on top of Google
Cloud store in addition to that we also
save the queries into the translation
store which is a layer on top of google
data store and this is used to further
analyze the query to improve our service
and also to improve the latency of the
request that the user sees and all right
so what we're going to do in this talk
is first to teach is going to take us
through how we eliminate errors server
errors 500s by taking a look at Google
Cloud logs and then I'm going to take a
look at the latency of this application
and how we can improve that with Google
Cloud trace and then I'm going to offer
a way to give you a deep insight into
how your application really works in
production with the Google Cloud
debugger all right so
finding problems in logs often times it
can feel like finding a needle in the
haystack there are lots of data that's
floating around but there's not that
much information that you can glean from
the logs so cool here has ever been on
call anybody alright so if you've ever
been on call you have you probably
remember this feeling of getting page at
four in the morning when your system
with something's going wrong and in your
system is on fire so it looks like she's
still in her pajamas here too so so when
that happens you to figure out what's
going on right so your production system
can often look like this and there's a
client browser that talks to an app
server that consults a compute cluster
that does is a sequel query that which
stores are resolved in a cloud store for
example and you probably replicate your
production system as well so 24 fault
tolerance so they're multiple copies of
your components now so when one copy of
it goes wrong which one do you know
which one do you which one can you tell
right that's going on so oftentimes
people look at logs but logs are
everywhere because you have multiple
components and so the process of
debugging systems log the old way is you
find you notified about a problem you
guess which component has the problem
ussa to do the machine and look at the
logs if you find out if you find the
problem log grade if don't the cycle
repeats and once you find the problem
then what you have to go to another
debugging tool reenter the context of
your investigation to further root cause
the problem or if you're good you just
edit the code and redeploy so what do
you want to do in the modern way of
debugging with logs is to eliminate the
cycle of guessing we want you to be able
to search logs in aggregate find a
problem log right away and from there
seamlessly navigate to other debugging
tools without having to re-enter on the
context and go about solving the problem
so to do
that I will show you a demo of cloud
logs with emoji translator so please
switch to demo machine please thank you
so it's keisha it looks like the green
bar there we've got a lot of 500 yeah
yeah well we've been deploying to
service for a while and let's check to
see how is doing if I can click on this
all right so um de moguer my I reread
all right okay so we do we do see a lot
of um the 500 errors they yeah we do see
a lot of errors here so the green line
here that I'm showing you is the
airlines um you can see here there
they're coming up they're not they're
not really flat so looks like there's a
problem there I haven't touched the
deployment in a while no I didn't push
anything I've been at this conference it
wasn't me all right I was getting my
makeup done so I haven't done anything
either so it must be the intern must be
that engineer behind all right so all
right well I'm going to do is I'm going
to revert back to a stable version that
we have deploy sign that I know that
doesn't have any problems so this is a
common thing we do at Google as soon as
we spot an issue an alert goes off we
see a raise rise in errors before we go
in debug it the first thing we do is
roll back to the previous version that
we know is good so that we stop the
experience that customers have right
away and so a teacher's doing that with
App Engine switching it back to a
previous version yeah so once we do that
then we can okay rest assure that users
are getting the responses are not
getting the 500s and then now we can go
on and and investigate the problem so
let's go back to the App Engine
dashboard here we scroll down through
the lit so down the page will see that
there bunch of server errors and a lot
of them and in fact 33,000 I'm coming
from this request that translates late
the emoji so yeah yes
lata error well we're sanara is a lot of
good there's a lot of errors yes a one
is conveniently if I click on this link
it takes me straight to the logs viewer
and and it filters the logs to just the
request path the request path that has
translate on it and with just that as
500s so notice what we've done here
we're actually running this front-end on
several front-end instances we've
gathered the logs from all of those
front-end instances we've aggregated
them and given you a chronological view
and a teacher's going to show you how
you can filter sort that data all in one
place there's so there's no more ss-18
into each machine checking out is this
the one that has the problem yeah that's
right we can also filter just to see the
error log so now over here we can see oh
yeah they're all errors so but if you
want to make sure you only want to see
error logs in your application you can
just filter that as well the logs viewer
are also offers infinite scroll so you
won't have to click Next anymore to see
your logs you just scroll up and down
and we just keep loading the logs for
you and in addition you can livestream
your logs from all your instances so is
the tail dash F for your logs from from
every single copy of your deployment
this is a great vanity thing at yishun I
both work on the cloud developer console
and we do this just go look at what's
going on let me just see the amount of
traffic that we're getting what are
people actually doing on the site yes
unfortunately we have reverted to a
stable version so we're not getting any
more errors as you see here that live
stream is not showing us more errors
which is great all right now let's look
at just one log here if you click and
expand the request logs will show you
the app logs that corresponds to that
request locks I'm there there's a stack
trace here where those receptions being
thrown hmm I haven't seen this before
yeah but you know it looks like some of
those are blue that's kind of a
indication that it might be a link well
it looks like this is our code but
haven't touched it in a while so
fortunately the log viewer show you a
link straight into the code that amidst
that problem when I click on that it
takes me
to the source browser and directly
exactly to the line where the exception
is thrown so that we actually knew not
only where the source code was but we
knew what version of the source could
correspond to what was in production at
that time we also knew what file in line
cause that issue that the greatly speeds
up the debugging in fact you you can use
this at Google as well right you have
yes exactly in turn our internal tools
also offer these seamless navigation
between the logs and the source and they
use it all the time so right fortunately
there is a bug here and it looks like
hmm looks like somebody put an easter
egg into our code yeah it's a in the
case where we're translating the word
die it says what does it say ha ha die
get it it's an accept that's uh it's not
funny now's not now so it seems like our
intern got a little excited and put this
easter egg n so maybe we should take
care of that yeah so i can force i can
edit the code right in the source
browser i click edit here and it changes
in edit mode i just commented out we
don't need to throw this exception here
and i can just commit and once I enter
this commit message check out easter egg
so what's going to happen now is a tisha
is going to commit that back to the free
private git repository that's associated
with each cloud project and then that
will kick off our continuous integration
continuous delivery pipeline that in our
case uses Jenkins sinks it down does a
build runs our unit tests if those paths
pushes it back out to the version she's
specified yeah it's gonna take a while
to a mite taken away but fortunately we
have a fixed version already yeah what
would show the doesn't list do you have
the dough yeah that's right yeah so just
to get us since we've been working on
the demo a little bit so there's the
list of changes we've made recently you
can look at the bill logs diff from from
release to release what was the code
change that happened and we found that
really handy alright so since we just
remember we've reverted to a fixed
version at the beginning of this talk so
I can let's go back and look at our
errors and see what's happening
they're all right so back in the App
Engine dashboard the default now is 41
which we reverted to and we can show
error details 41 within the past hour
and look that has a lot fewer there are
no server errors that our client errors
yeah there's sky NER that's a different
that's the JavaScript guys brought all
right okay but our server is clean that
was the goal off that's great can we
switch back to slides please alright so
slides please so to recap we showed you
two how to roll back your production to
a previous stable version when there is
an error in your current one that you
just pushed we also show how to filter
logs from all the versions from from all
the instances of your deployment and we
also seamlessly navigate from monitoring
two logs and to the source code and then
fix the problem right in the console so
to recap again cloud logs you can search
through all your logs just in our just
in the single console you can seem
please navigate from monitoring from
trace and from source and we're going to
add more integration with other tools
soon there's infinite scroll and live
streaming which is held a sh f for all
your logs and it's available for App
Engine managed VMs and compute engine
which is coming soon thank you alright
so a t-shirt just talk to you a little
bit about using cloud logs to debug the
service and I'm going to talk about
latency so our applications just been
out for a little while we've already got
some users unfortunately some of our
users are not having the best possible
experience here it looks like Lady
Macbeth is running into a latency issue
with our application so let's walk
through the process of tracking down
lady macbeth's issue and getting a fix
out into production so if we look at our
average response time it's fairly
respectable 100 milliseconds is a pretty
good average response time but averages
when you're talking about the latency of
an application can be very misleading
you might naively expect your latency
distribution to look something like this
kind of a standard bell-shaped
distribution curve with your latency
along the bottom x-axis number requests
up the y-axis that then it would be a
standard curve but if you've actually
done some latency work you know it
rarely looks like this it must much more
commonly looks like this where you have
a long tail of latency so when you're
using the site you fall into this green
bar you get a great experience it's
really fast for you right the bulk of
your users maybe get a reasonable
experience faster reasonable experience
and then there's where Lady Macbeth is
way out there on the end and psychology
tells us that a few bad experiences like
that have an outsized impact on users
perception of the latency of your
application and to make matters worse it
looks like there's even a little bump in
latency way out there on the end so we
call this long tail latency so Jeff Dean
is senior fellow at Google he wrote many
of our internal systems BigTable
MapReduce now he's working on Google
brain and he has a quote that we like to
use internally and that is that it's
important to examine the long tail of a
system long tail latency of systems even
when they appear fast so with Jeff is
talking about here is using percentiles
rather than averages so if you look at
these series of latency measurements
that we did we see the average is around
one hundred and two milliseconds but the
90th percentile that is ninety percent
of requests have this want this score or
better this latency or faster the 90th
percentile is way up in the 300
millisecond range which isn't really
appropriate for this site so it's much
better to look at that 90th percentile
in order to bring this home let's
consider two applications say you have
application one which has this curve in
blue an application to
with the red curve which one would you
be more proud of which one would you
rather have in production for your
application well if you've been paying
attention you know that we should ignore
averages averages have nothing to do
with this we really need to know what
the percentile what is the 95th
percentile for these two applications to
help us bring that home so if we look at
this you can see application one while
it has a faster average has a much worst
95th percentile and that's because
application one has a long tail latency
problem so we want to avoid that so
let's take a look at a demo of cloud
trace and how it can help you find that
so switch over to the demo machine so
we're back in the logs viewer that esha
showed and I want to point out the
millisecond columns here this tells us
we're measuring how long each HTTP
request took from the time it entered
the server until the time it returns
something back and these numbers
actually look pretty good at esha I
don't know oh well so my heart all right
yeah let's click on one notice these are
blue again so we can click on them so I
clicked on this first one and it brought
us into Google Cloud trace Google Cloud
trace is a HTTP profiling utility that
helps you see the exact time you're
spinning on your application so let me
zoom in here so you can get a better
look the green bar the 40 milliseconds
that's overall from beginning from the
time it hits your server until the time
it leaves it was 40 milliseconds of that
40 milliseconds 28 of it was in a
datastore put so in this case what we're
doing the translation request comes in
we do the translation and then we store
it into the datastore that takes the 29
milliseconds if you examine a few of
these requests you'll start to get a
feeling of the variance that is common
for datastore and this gives you
transparency is it your problem that the
application is slow or is it Google's
problem so this will really help you
isolate that to see if you know our data
centers are having a bad day which
rarely happens but it gives you train
perrin see and you can find out what's
going on with that but again this
latency actually looks pretty good
there's not much wrong here let's go
back and look at the trace list so the
trace list shows us we're profiling
almost every request that comes in we do
some sampling so this can be an
always-on service and you can see here
we're getting pretty good Layton sees on
here but yeah but you know these are all
just anecdotal evidence yeah don't you
want to collect some sitesi just like an
engineer right she wants to actually get
some data to make a decision so let's
see if we can help with that so we'll
switch over to the reports tab here and
what this will do is give us an
opportunity to create a report over a
large series of data so I'll click
request report and the we want to look
at that translate URI and then on the
version we want version 42 and let's
just look at it over the last hour so I
can click Submit here and that's going
to take just a minute to run out over
all our data and do a report i happen to
have done one earlier to save us a
little bit of time so let's take a look
at this report so if we drill in here
notice it looks similar to what we saw
before where there is most of the
requests so sorry the latency in
milliseconds is down on the x-axis and
percentage of total requests are along
the y-axis so we want everything to be 2
up and to the left in this case but what
we're seeing is there is way over here
at the 4000 millisecond range there's a
little hump of requests that's the long
tail latency yeah that's where Lady
Macbeth yeah that might be where the
experience Lady Macbeth is having with
our site so let's see if we can isolate
that further so if we scroll down in
this report what you'll see is an actual
breakdown by percentile of where your
latency is being spent so we can see
we're actually having a pretty good
experience at the 90th percentile so
ninety percent of the requests are
coming in 21 200 milliseconds and if you
want to have just an ok service you can
stop there
but if you wanna have a great service
you need to go look at 95 and 99.5
latency and there you're getting six
seconds that's a ridiculous amount of
time so what we've done to help debug
that is we've actually grabbed a few
sample traces so give me a few that fall
into this category so that I can examine
those more so which one should we should
we check out anything yeah I think we
should look at the 95th percentile 95
how about the first yeah we'll just look
at the first one here great so again it
looks very similar to what we saw before
the green bars the overall amount of
time but now we're seeing a call to URL
fetch that's the App Engine way goes out
to the public internet to download data
so at esha why are we in the middle of a
translate why are we calling URL fetch
that's our intern yeah and yes so we
don't intend that to so we we now just
just by looking at this data we have
some indication there is a mysterious
URL fetch maybe if we view the logs so
I'm going to click on the logs here and
notice what this is going to do we
actually are filtering the logs by this
unique request ID so take all the
gigabytes of logs that we have and show
me just those logs that are from this
one request that we pulled out of that
sample report yeah and I just want to
recap with Brad just is so he just went
from the logs viewer and checked out
along a request latency and click that
and went straight into the cloud trace
UI and it looked at the trace reports
and even checked out some of the traces
and then and then navigated back to the
logs we were all within the developers
console without having to leave it and
reenter information everything is
seamless very integrated experience so
if we look at this logs we see this long
that's highlighted is in experiment for
getting related Twitter feeds are you
doing an experiment on that sounds
suspicious and then if you look at the
rest of the logs it looks like we're
actually pulling data from Twitter into
the logs that's that's very troubling
this so let's go
he showed you how to look at the source
code in the cloud console but many of us
have developer tools that we know and
love and so let's look at my favorite
one and we'll look at the source code on
my local machine so here I can come and
search for that experiment and looks
like it was already commented out what
we see in production it looks like this
so this is what's in production and what
we see there is it looks like it looks
like we're doing some experiment like
five percent of traffic is actually
getting a twitter feed that's uh that's
kind of troubling I don't think that's
the right thing to do here so what we'll
do is just comment this code out and
then have a conversation with the intern
later about that and then at this point
what we can do is just use tools we know
and love so we use get already so we can
just do a git commit to our local
machine then do a git push to send that
up to the cloud and that will trigger
our continuous delivery pipeline that
will do a build on Jenkins run our test
if those past deploy but again that'll
take a minute so Julia Child style I
already have a version of the
application in production with the fix
yes so I have that fix in production but
we want to verify right like we don't
want to just trust that that was the
issue we want to measure again and make
sure thats really fixes the issue so to
do that let's switch back over to cloud
trace and we're going to generate
another report this time we're going to
do a report that compares between two
different instances so we're still going
to look at that translate URL and we're
going to compare 42 with that fixed
version don't you wish you had that
fixed version for your application it's
it's quite handy we're going to look at
that say over the last 24 hours in both
cases so we could go ahead and submit
that but that'll take a minute to run so
I already have this one created for us
ahead of time so what you're seeing here
is the two
versions of the application the blue 42
is the old one it has the experiment
running in it and then B is the one we
fixed right so if we examine here it
looks like way out here in the long tail
latency you can see that be has that
hump that we saw before the long tail
latency hump and sorry a has that and B
does not so it seems like we fix this
issue yeah I think we have done Jeff
Dean proud yeah I think yes I definitely
think we're ready for a peer bonus for
having done this so if we look at the
percentiles the stories even more clear
you can see while the old version does
marginally better for the fastest twenty
five percent and the long tail latency
it's very clear that our fixed version
is significantly better so okay that's
Google Cloud trace the switch back over
to the slides what we saw if we switch
back to slide yeah good what we saw in
this demo is that we looked at how to go
from logs back to the trace so you can
right in the middle of your examining
logs you can go look at trace data then
we saw how you can use percentiles very
easily with the Google cloud trace
reports to narrow down on exactly what
the issue is and then last we saw how
you can actually verify that you're
improving the latency situation with new
releases by doing a version to version
comparison in the console so Google
Cloud trace is very low overhead it's
designed to be an always-on experience
it today it works on App Engine and
managed VMs and on all those languages
that are supported in App Engine and it
is just weeks away from being ready
we're putting the last spit polish on it
it'll be ready for you in just a couple
of weeks and so look forward to that
announcement wow I wish I could use that
you get a t-shirt you can you can you
can use that right now right okay um so
let's turn our attention to the Google
Cloud debugger
it's designed to help you get deep
insight into how your application is
running in production so my observation
of the way I work and when I talk to
developers they seem to work when
they're debugging production issues is
they get some problem reports some their
boss comes in yell at them there's a
tweet from somebody like Lady Macbeth
there's some problem report the first
thing you do is go to the modern
monitoring dashboard or go looking logs
for what might the problem be and then
the next thing you do if you're a
developer is you go stare at code right
isn't staring at code kind of a big part
of your day you go stare code and try to
get some insight try to map what you're
seeing in the logs and the bug report
with what you see in the code and then
inevitably the information you need is
not in the logs so you go and add more
logging and of course when you add more
logging you need to redeploy the
application into production and then you
need to search the logs again stare at
code some more yet again add more
logging and this cycle continues until
you stumble upon the solution is that is
that about right okay well my
observation is this is not how it always
was it seems to me that back in the good
old days we had a we had a better
solution for this back in the good old
days where I used to debug fat client
applications they ran on one machine on
one processor on one thread I could just
stare at the code I could set a
breakpoint and then I would view my
locals and if this the solution would
come very quickly this was a much faster
iteration cycle for finding bugs so why
can't we have this experience for cloud
applications right so why can't we have
this for cloud applications well the
first is our systems in the cloud are
much more interdependent there's what's
called the Heisenberg effect that you
can't both be debugging and reproduce
the bug at the same time have you had
that experience
because our systems are so
interdependent when you try to debug one
part of the system it changes the
timings that changes everything else is
going on in the system are in we have a
large degree of instance replication
even medium-sized services have two
three a thousand ten thousand instances
running in production how are you
possibly to know which instance to walk
up to and set a breakpoint on or attach
a debug or two it's impossible to know
and finally you can't break this is
production you can't break in production
I can't say I'm going to take my
e-commerce site and you know whoever
happens did i'm just going to take this
service offline whoever happens to hit
is going to going to have a terrible
experience like you can't do that in
production that's that's not wise so
what we really want the cycle of
debugging in the modern cloud in my
dream world looks like this you can
stare at code you set these watch points
and you can still view local variables
but for this to be true I we needed to
attach to all the instances
simultaneously I would need it to have
negligible performance impact if I'm
going to run this in production if it's
not going to have the Heisenberg effect
it has to have almost no performance
impact and finally it has to actually
give me the data I need they access to
the stack and locals as you might guess
we're going to demo this so let's switch
over to the demo machine so the tisha I
think you were saying there's a bug here
right yeah I also want to get drinks
tonight too and I was trying that query
okay yeah city tonight yeah drinks in
the city tonight so clear what's wrong
with that drink city when when are we
having drinks oh well we're not question
my no I added the other the other day i
added tonight there's tonight yeah we
have tonight it's not a question okay we
have tonight and ? look we're both
tonight and ? what's the row oh I think
the problem might be that we don't have
them when they're together okay so we
have tonight space ? works but tonight ?
with no space that doesn't work okay
so that's the bug yeah that's the bug so
we're going to use the Google Cloud
debugger to isolate why we're having
this bug in production so let's switch
over to one of our mini tabs and is this
lessons okay so what we're seeing again
we use get to push our source code up to
the private git repository you can also
associate your bitbucket or github
account with this if you'd like it all
still works and what we're doing we're
going to start off the debugger with
this translate endpoint actually the
first thing imma do is get rid of the
left nav you can get rid of the left nav
did you know that just by clicking at
the bottom there and then I'm going to
use the debugger so there's a new debug
icon if we go and click on that what it
will do is give me an opportunity to set
a watch point so in this case I want to
see what the value of this content is
notice we're not actually logging
content seems like something I want to
know so i'm going to set a watch point
right here so now what's happening is
it's the debugger is going out to all
our instances and it's saying tell me
when line 85 is executed by any of you
as soon as the first one execute line 85
we briefly pause execution of that
process we grab the stock and locals and
return that data back and let the
process go about its way so you don't
even notice that that process ever got
paused so we can go continue and here
you're seeing we get that value so the
content this query was kiss somebody in
the audience is interesting okay so we
can we can hit refresh here and let's
just get another one and see what's
happening i'll push my luck and see if
we get another one died so okay Batman
not gonna put those just Joab what Brad
is doing here so with the cloud debugger
he can capture a request that that's
been sent to our system and look at all
the stack trace associated with that
request and then let the request go and
the user still gets the response back
this all this without with was just
microseconds of pause
I'm sorry I keep going it's okay and yes
okay all right so let's take a look at
image URLs and see if we can figure out
there that looks like that might
possibly be the problem so we'll look at
that one this query is do you want to
get drinks in the city tonight and but I
want to drill in on image URL so I'll
just open that up and you can see we're
getting we have ten images return that
sounds good but if we drill in what you
see is we're returning a bunch of blank
images and one that says cocktails so
drinks in the city we're getting
cocktails so we we get we're getting
some understanding of what's going on
with this application but notice that
query is not exactly the 1i wanted to
debug this one was drinks in the city
tonight do you want get drinks in the
city and the question we had was
specifically about tonight ? so we don't
want to stop on any requests to this
line we only want to break when a
certain condition happens in that
condition is when tonight ? is the
content so we can do that with the
condition so we will do khon2 content
dot index of and what this is is
standard Java whatever language you're
debugging you get to write a predicate
in that language and what was it tonight
? and we want to say that greater than
or equal to 0 so it's got to be a
condition that evaluates to true or
false so now what's happening is on
every one of the instances again we
farmed it out to all of them we wait for
that line to be executed when that line
is executed we run the condition over
that line if that condition is false we
just let it go if that condition is true
we stop grab the stock and locals let
the let it go on have a small pause and
let it go on and bring back that data so
what you're seeing now is we're able to
isolate to just the ones we want that
not work all right yeah we're going one
more time do it again
content index of tonight yeah this one
worked okay you can tell it's in beta
okay so notice in this case we're
getting all blanks all of the items
returned or blank blank that's they're
all blank so there must be a problem in
that get image URLs so you see we we
started with the request we worked our
way down this method now we know it's in
a different method so we're isolating
where that bug is so let's scroll down
into this and we'll set a breakpoint
this is in get image URLs sorry we're
set a watch point to get image URLs and
you can see what this code is doing here
we canonicalize this string make sure
you can read it we canonicalize the
string uppercase lowercase that kind of
thing we split on space and then we do a
switch statement that's our advanced
artificial intelligence that we're using
to do the translation and then you can
see conveniently tonight is the first
one at the at the top of the list so we
need to compare word with tonight yeah
so to recap what brad has been doing so
far is he is narrowing down where the
problem in the code is and he's doing
that by filtering on the request which
on only the quest that has the word
tonight and whenever there's request
with that phrase and it will trigger the
watch point in the code so what you're
seeing is anybody figure this out yet
anybody got it somebody's got it okay so
even from the back row we can figure
this out so you can see the word is
tonight ? but the switch statement is
switching on just tonight so it's an
exact match on the string and so it's
not actually matching and falling
through the default to give you that so
in this case the fix that we have in
mind here is that canonicalize is a
little bit buggy so we can come in here
and we can say sure enough there's a bug
don't you wish your code had this nice
hint in it where the bugs are so we see
the bug and like a tisha showed at this
point we can just come into the editor
and go ahead
and find this we can go ahead and commit
that back to our production repository
again that might take a minute so we
already have a fixed version out in
production so let's take a look at that
so you can get to a particular app
engine version by putting the version
first so this is the fixed version so oh
actually before we do that on push my
luck before we do that let's switch over
if you notice over here this is the
debugging target I'm going to switch
over to fixed right so I want to be
debugging the one we have in production
and notice as soon as I do that oh yeah
we got to discard the change yes oh we
don't have the code okay we don't have
the code if we had the code it would
switch us over to exactly that version
of the code so the debugger knows what
version of the code we want to debug but
let's go see if we have this fixed so
we'll look at tonight ? and we expect to
see two images right so let's see if we
actually do and there it is beautiful
so what we just saw here is the power of
using watch points so that you can set a
line of code look at the stock and
locals from there we talked about how
you can set conditions so those watch
points are only triggered when a certain
condition happens and we talked about
that version the source mapping the
debugger knows what version is there so
the Google Cloud debugger enables this
kind of modern debugging in the cloud
that we talked about in terms of
performance it the evaluation so first
off just having the debugger available
has no performance impact if you if you
haven't set a watch point there's no
performance impact whatsoever as soon as
you set a watch point and we start
listening there for every request
there's a 40 milliseconds for TMI
Christine 40 micro seconds she gives me
a hard time about this 40 micro seconds
to evaluate like is this the line we
should stop on so and it's actually our
measure time is less than that but our
threshold is is that in the event that
one of them actually hits your condition
and we actually have to fight we fire
the debugger we pause for less than 10
milliseconds and two that's to capture
the stock so if you think about the
performance of your application what a
10 millisecond overhead to get this kind
of experience on that one request be a
problem so it gives you access to the
stock and locals this is on by default
so there's no setup required and you're
able to use this today with managed VMs
and java code so we are working hard to
make it available for other languages
and other environments but what's
available for you to use today is
managed VMs Java and you just have to
have your source code up in the git
repository that that we offer ok I'm
going to wrap this up yeah so to wrap up
what we showed you today is how to
eliminate errors in your production
system with cloud logs this is the URL
we can go to to find out more
information we also showed you how to
debug
latency issues with cloud trace generate
reports and compare two versions of your
code to see if you have eliminated the
performance problem and lastly what Brad
just showed you was with cloud debugger
you can capture the request that comes
into your system capture the stack trace
look at evaluates execution let the
request go you can keep doing that until
you narrow down where your problem is
and with that these are the contact
information for our session thank you
alright thank you and we we have about 3
V 3 or 4 minutes for questions so any
unique there I think there are mics
right here and right here to sewing it
on recording there's any questions if
not will be available offline no one
want to fund our remote it must have
laid completely clear somebody coming
yeah
yeah so the question was that there is
sort of a choice to be made me app
engine compute engine will these do
these tools work on one or the other how
does that work so our goal with a
platform all up is to have a seamless
continuum and have you be able to use
basically use these tools on whatever
part of the platform stack you you
choose to use and so yeah so that's our
that's our goal there at various stages
of being ready for different ones so
yeah we do we do have plan to show logs
from all of your all your services in
your project in one in one view together
merge so including raw beams right
getting raw computer dm's will actually
suck the we know where the apache logs
are and where you know Hadoop stores its
logs and will suck all those and put
them into the same log viewer data tisha
showed in terms of cloud trace we're
also working on a model to get that HTTP
profiling utility available for GCE and
container engine as well and then for
the debugger that'll actually come out
on compute engine relatively they told
me not to commit two dates but
relatively soon other questions okay
Becky yeah
yes good question so I mentioned our git
repository you can go associate your
bitbucket or github account just doing
the OAuth dance you can associate your
github project and if you when you
commit to the master branch of your
github project or your bitbucket project
it'll just mirror into our cloud and we
have a read-only mirror of your source
so all the debugger stuff and whatnot
will just keep working okay so I think
we're out of time but sorry one more one
more okay any plans to support order to
get submodels sorry get submodels
submodels Oh sub modules so something
you're saying a deployment unit smaller
than a module or we make sure I get it
get has an amazing future to combine
different repositories in one it's bold
to get submodels I see okay let's follow
up after on that we definitely want to
stay current with whatever the state of
the art is with that so we're happy to
talk about that okay thank you very much
appreciate it